earlier in the day the president said
he's feeling vibrant and young at age 72
and he thinks he has a big advantage in
energy over seventy six-year-old to
Abidin and other Democrats looking to
take his job Biden had to expend a lot
of energy today defending himself in
what would normally be considered
friendly territory
here's correspondent Peter Doocy this
isn't Jill Biden's first campaign but
it's the first time he's asked himself
about what's appropriate
I actually thought in my head when I
walked out here I mean do i we're
friends
Biden is much more familiar with
fundraising his day old campaign already
has six point three million dollars in
the bank the highest 24-hour total of
any Democrat running aren't these
campaigns over long ago in his record is
long too he recently called anita hill
to express regret about the 1991 hearing
he chaired where some lawmakers doubted
her claims of misconduct against
Clarence Thomas apology not accepted
Hill now tells the New York Times quote
I cannot be satisfied by simply saying
I'm sorry for what happened to you I
will be satisfied when I know there is
real change and real accountability and
real purpose I don't think I treated her
badly this is what Biden said in 1991 it
is appropriate to ask professor Hill
anything any member wishes to ask her to
plumb the depths of her credibility
president Trump's focus isn't on an old
hearing it's on old age I am a young
vibrant man
I look at Joe I don't know about him
trumpet 72 Biden is 76 if he looks young
and vibrant compared to me I should
probably go home the president is also
trying to tag the Democratic frontrunner
and sleepy Joe that's the first time
I've ever been referenced that way by
anyone else maybe nobody else has called
Biden sleepy but he did call himself
sleepy caucus night 2008 I shouldn't
tell you this
I feel like Harry Truman I went back to
the room and I fell asleep till it was
over
later that year Biden became Obama's
running mate and believes they kept
things squeaky-clean at 1600 not one
single whisper of scandal but president
Trump alleges that someone in the Obama
administration is responsible for maybe
the biggest scandal in political history
even bigger than water date that's
bordering surveillance on his campaign
Biden might not have heard a whisper
about it at the White House but he'll
hear about it now
Janan yeah and our panel is gonna talk
about it at the back end of the show
Peter thank you thanks